So, we're going to be covering
the truth behind God's name. I'm sure
you've heard it in sermons and songs in
church.
Um for from those who say you need to
say
a certain name for God.
And
I kind of had to clear all that noise
out and go, "Okay.
God, what
is the truth behind this? What is your
name?"
And
it's what I do with every topic. I
prayed about it. I studied it. And as I
dove into it,
I will be showing you everything I
found.
So, we're going to be looking
at tracing the names, following the
symbols.
And every spirit will be tested in this.
So, let's get into it.
All right. As we look at the etymology
and history, it's important. I'm not
going to read all these, but I am going
to tell you
that as we look at these verses, Jehovah
in the original is what God's name is.
Now, when we go further, we will see it
again in Exodus 6:3. It says, "And I
appeared unto Abraham,
unto Isaac, and unto Jacob by the name
of God Almighty,
but by my name Jehovah was I not known
to them."
And here's other examples. Again, I
won't read all of them, but Jehovah
Jireh, Jehovah
Nissi, Jehovah Shalom.
All right.
And we're going to take a look at the
fact that in the King James version of
the Bible,
God's personal name is often represented
by the Hebrew
Tetragrammaton
Y H W H and is replaced with the title
Lord in all caps approximately 6,000
823 times throughout the Bible. So, that
makes you question what's going on here,
right?
Let's take a look.
This man
Nehemia Gordon,
never heard of him before until this
topic came up. Some pretty interesting
discoveries I found on this. So, let's
go ahead and take a look. During these
Hadrianic persecutions, they forbade the
Jews from speaking the name Jehovah.
Specifically, they said, "You must not
speak the name of your God the way it's
written." And that's where we get this
this replacement where it was spoken
Adonai. And we're told about one
particular rabbi who I've been to his
tomb in the Galilee. His name is Hanina
ben Teradion. And we're told he was
burned at the stake, wrapped in a Torah
scroll that was set on fire because he
spoke the name the way it was written.
And this is sometime around the year 136
between 136 and 138. Okay. So, that's
all this 100 years after Yeshua's
ministry, he's being burned at the
stake, this rabbi, for speaking the name
the way it was written.
Okay. So, that's one thing that this guy
Nehemia Gordon found out. He's a
theologian and
if they banned the name, the Jews did,
to be spoken and started writing it as
Hashem,
which means the name, just just
the name, when did the name Yahweh
actually come into being is the
question.
And they found that the name Yahweh was
first introduced in the 16th century by
a man named Gilbert
Genebrard,
professor of Hebrew at the College Royal
in Paris.
He derived it from the Tetragrammaton
Y H W H. Now,
you need to hang in here with me. This
Tetragrammaton is very important
understanding. We're going to be
unpacking it little by little all the
way until the end.
So,
let's continue.
We also find that during his time in
1580 78, he went to Rome where he was
honorably received by Pope Sixtus V and
stood in close relation to Cardinal
Allen,
Baronius, Bosio, and other
ecclesiastical celebrities. Upon his
return in 1588,
he became one
of the chief supporters of the Holy
League in France.
Okay. The Holy League in France
is a Catholic League
that was a powerful group of French
Catholics who played a significant role
in the St. Bartholomew's Day Massacre in
1572.
Now, if I'm not mistaken, I'm using my
memory, but I remember studying St.
Bartholomew's Day Massacre Massacre and
um
it was very very twisted.
They set up kind of like a time for
Christians to be free
um or something. They were going to be
allowed
to speak about their faith with others
or something and they made a date. They
set that date.
Or maybe it was like a peace treaty or
something that they were going to write
up.
But when the Catholics arrived to this
meeting on that day, all they came with
was
swords and knives and they massacred
3,000 people.
3,000 Christians.
And so, unbeknownst to the Christians,
they were going to be slaughtered.
So, they didn't even know what was
coming. Next, we find that Josephus, if
you know of the theologian Bible scholar
Josephus says in 168 BC, the Samaritans
stopped using God's name out of
tradition and persecution
and had decided, or sorry, dedicated
their temple to Jupiter.
So, an interesting twist
comes about.
In 1833,
we see that Wilhelm
Gesenius, I guess,
a prominent German Hebrew scholar,
proposed Yahweh as a possible
pronunciation of the Hebrew divine name,
the Tetragrammaton
Y H W H once again,
which is very important again. We're
going to get to that.
Gesenius faced conflict with the church
due to his rationalism views and its
association with Freemasonry.
All right. So, there's one link. He also
received verbal attacks because he made
comments during lectures that treated
lightly the biblical accounts of
miracles.
He was thereafter troubled with personal
stresses.
In 1833, he nearly died of lung disease.
And in 1835, three of his children died
and subsequently he was tormented by
various physical complaints.
His death in 1842 came after prolonged
misery from gallstones.
You made the shift and you're now saying
Jehovah. I want to I want to explain to
people where where Yahweh comes from.
>> Okay. Please do.
>> For cuz for 200 years the world has been
deceived. And not really the Jewish
world. The Jewish world doesn't know
anything about this. The academic
scholarly world, which then spilled over
into the Christian world, has been
deceived by this information. I think
it's deception. And I when I dug into
where it came from, I was shocked cuz
where it came from is Gesenius. Gesenius
is the great grammarian of Hebrew
grammar. To this day, the primary
lexicons of biblical Hebrew, Brown
Driver Briggs and Halot, Hebrew and
Aramaic Lexicon of the Old Testament,
are based on the work of Gesenius
uh in the 1800s.
And the primary
uh grammar at Hebrew University, I would
sit with these uh in these classes and
these
you know, the professor would assign an
assignment to go check in the Hebrew
grammar. And the Hebrew grammar of the
grammar of biblical Hebrew isn't in
Hebrew. It's in English or German,
written by Gesenius. So, we had students
I was sitting with who were native
Hebrew speakers who would come to me and
say, "Can you help us? Our English isn't
good enough." I'm like, "Yeah, I can
read this, you know, it's it's English.
It's my native language." Um and so,
Gesenius' Hebrew grammar is is really
the foundation of modern Hebrew of of
biblical studies in Hebrew. And even
today at Hebrew University
>> University, and rightfully so. He was he
did groundbreaking work. What he really
did is he collected things that were
done by other people over centuries and
he put them as as Germans are quite good
at doing and especially in the past is
doing things in a systematic way. Mhm.
And so, he was very systematic. He is
wonderful. I consult Gesenius almost
every day, Michael. I'm not saying he's
a bad grammar. I'm just saying he didn't
get everything right. And what And if
you look at the earlier versions of his
dictionary
in particular, you get a glimpse into
his thought pattern of where he So, he
was the one who championed Yahweh and
convinced the scholarly world it should
be Yahweh cuz it was a debate in the
Christian world up until then. Meaning
Yahweh doesn't appear until 1599. That's
the first time it appears in the
writings of a man named Gilbert
Genebrard.
And then it's debated for a couple
hundred years by the Christians that
Jehovah, which the Jews seem to think it
is, or is it Yahweh? And then then
Gesenius ends the discussion as Yahweh.
And he brings two pieces of evidence
which shocked me cuz I didn't know this
until very relatively recently.
And he says this in the 1833 edition of
his dictionary, which was translated in
1857 into English. And in the
dictionary, uh this part I actually
didn't know the first part. So, the
first part is that the main source for
Yahweh is a Christian church father
named Theodoret of Cyrus who lived at
the end of the 4th, beginning of the 5th
century AD. And what Theodoret of Cyrus
says is he's talking about the name and
he makes a statement that is quoted in
in certainly every scholarly work on
this topic as evidence for Yahweh. And
what Theodoret says in his questions on
Exodus chapter 7, question number 15, he
says the Samaritans call it Yahweh while
the Jews call it Iah, which is really
interesting because he's at first you
think he's talking about the
Tetragrammaton, YHVH,
right? And that's what's understood
certainly when it comes to the
Samaritans, but he says the Jews call
God's name Iah. Well, what's Iah? So,
years ago I suggested that Iah,
which supposedly the Jews refer to God
as, was
a corruption of the Yah that you have in
Hallelujah. And that's definitely a
possibility.
Meaning he's not even talking about the
Tetragrammaton when it comes to the Jews
cuz by the time of Theodoret of Cyrus,
there were very
small number of Jews who still spoke the
name. It was kept as a secret among the
rabbis and certainly this Gentile
wouldn't have heard it. Like that makes
no sense that this Christian from some,
you know, from Cyrus and Theodora, not
Cyprus by the way,
that he would have heard this. It
doesn't doesn't make sense.
So, where did they hear this from and
and how did he get this information from
the Samaritans? Remember, we just heard
from Josephus that in 168 BC the
Samaritans didn't speak the name of the
God of Israel. In fact, they had an
they referred to God by no name,
anonymous, and then they rededicated
their temple to Zeus or Jupiter.
So, how So, that was 168 BC and now
we're being told
sometime around 500 AD by Theodoret of
Cyrus that 700 years later that the
Samaritans pronounce God's name as
Yahweh. So, where does he get that? So,
there's a couple of there's a number of
possibilities. One is well, maybe there
was some faction of Samaritans who did
speak it. I don't know. There isn't
really evidence for that. What some
scholars suggest, and by the way, this
is Gesenius' basis for Yahweh. This
statement by Theodoret, what I just read
to you, that is the only solid proof of
any kind for Yahweh.
This statement by Theodoret who's
quoting the Samaritans. By the way,
Theodoret didn't know Hebrew. The
Samaritans weren't even Israelites. So,
their form of Hebrew was a corrupt form
of Hebrew based on the northern dialect,
but it was corrupted over time. They
don't have the hay sound, for example.
This gentleman,
the the scholar, Samaritan scholar, he
says to me,
you know, the name of God means Hayah
Hoveh Yah. I said, "Well, how do you
pronounce that in Samaritan Hebrew?"
Hayah, he says is Abba.
Hoveh, he says is Ebby.
Yihyeh is Yebby. Right? So, you can see
some like some remnant there of Hebrew,
but their Hebrew is different than the
Hebrew that was preserved by the Jewish
people. It comes from a different
dialect and that was corrupted over
time. So, how on earth does Theodoret
know what the Samaritans call the God of
Israel?
So, one possibility is that, you know,
he heard them say some other word and he
just didn't really he heard maybe third
or fourth hand, right? Cuz I doubt he
ever met a Samaritan.
So, somehow the word gets to him that
they refer to God as Yahweh or Yahweh.
What they might have actually been
referring to is what we saw in Exodus
3:14 and other scholars have suggested
this that in Exodus 3:14
we saw that
God is called Ehyeh. He says, "I am."
And then he says, "This is what you'll
call me for the rest of time is YHVH,
which is he was, he is, he will be."
Okay, next one. And it's possible this
is true.
So,
the Samaritans we heard about from
Josephus rededicated their temple to to
Jupiter.
Well, what's Jupiter called in Latin? In
Latin he's not called Jupiter. First of
all, there's no J in Latin, right? So,
in Latin he's called Jupiter.
And I actually spoke to an expert in
Latin to confirm this. So, today in
Latin they say Yove or Jove for Jupiter.
Right.
>> But in early and that's that's where you
get in English where, you know, where
Sherlock Holmes says, "Oh, by Jove, I
think I've got it." He's saying, "By
Jupiter." What are you saying? You're
saying by Jove. That's what he was
saying. Can you believe that?
I don't I don't know what the English
were thinking back then in the 1800s,
but anyway, there's different forms of
Jupiter and I don't want to get too
complicated here, but there are
different what they call cases in in in
Latin. So, there's Jupiter,
Jovis, Jovi, Jovum, Jove, Jupiter, but
basically in the early Latin it wasn't a
V, it was a W.
And so, it wasn't pronounced Jove, it
was pronounced Jowe in Latin 2,000 years
ago.
So, now
we have this word Jowe and where do we
get Jupiter from Jowe? It Jupiter is
Jowepater, father Jowe. That is the name
of Jupiter that was the God of the
Latins, Jowe. And I heard that I'm like,
that sounds awfully like Yahweh.
And we know that the Samaritans
dedicated their temple to Jupiter,
Jupiter of the Greeks.
So, maybe if you went to a Samaritan and
said, "What's the name of the God in
that temple?" he would say to you,
"That's father Jowe, Jowepater."
So, wait a minute. So, maybe this is
what he they heard from the Samaritans.
It's just not the name of YHVH, the God
of Israel. Now, you say, "Okay, come on.
Uh
um uh
Gesenius isn't going to fall for that.
He knew Greek, he knew Latin. He learned
the Greek and Latin before he learned
Hebrew. He was a, you know, solid German
scholar back then. Even in your day I
think people learn learn Latin, right?
And you know, in the earlier generations
Europeans and and people from the West
learned Greek and Latin really well. And
so, he knew about Jowe being the name of
Jupiter and you think, how could there
be any connection between what what um
uh
what he said, what Gesenius, this great
German scholar of of Hebrew studies,
said and Jupiter? Well, he actually
admits that there is.
Let me read you what he says. And and I
heard saw this and I'm like,
there it is. It's it's the it's the
smoking gun.
These are the words of
Gesenius in his 1857
edition of his dictionary. He says, "I
suppose this word," referring to Yahweh,
and earlier in the paragraph he he says,
"Hey, this comes from the Samaritans,
Yahweh, which is Yahweh.
I suppose this word to be one of the
most remote antiquity.
Perhaps it's the same origin as Yowe
Jovis,
which is Jois, and Jupiter, meaning Jove
and Jupiter, and transferred from the
Egyptians to the Hebrews."
All right. So, we have here from the
Fitzwilliam
Museum
how the connection is made between
Jupiter here
and Egypt.
It says, "Male or female, divine or
mortal, willing or afraid."
Within mythology,
that's what I'm adding there,
Jupiter forced himself upon many
partners.
His love affairs and the offspring they
produced have inspired artists for
centuries.
On the same page, a little bit further
down, it says,
"Another strange and rather complex myth
provides a kind of reversal
of the Europa story.
When Jupiter fell in love with Io,
daughter of the river god Inachus,
he turned her into a white
heifer so that his wife would not
suspect that his eye had once more
roved.
But Juno was not deceived and the
jealous goddess claimed the
heifer as her own.
She set the hundred-eyed herdsman Argus
to guard Io
so that she might tempt Jupiter no
further.
The cunning god Mercury killed Argus,
however, thus releasing Io.
Juno in angry
sorry, in anger sent a gadfly to sting
the heifer and chase her all over the
world. So,
all you need to know is that in the
story
um
Jupiter was after Io. Io
was
supposed to be kept from being chased
away by this guy who's guarding her and
was chasing this fly was sent after her
by the guy
all over the world. So, traveling is
happening.
Here's where Egypt comes in. She finally
came to rest in Egypt where Jupiter
returned her to her human form and by
merely touching her impregnated her with
a son, Epaphus. Some writers record that
she was worshipped in Egypt as the
goddess Isis.
Epaphus has been identified with the
Egyptian bull god Apis or Apis.
Here's where I need to take the moment
to thank some other people who have
helped me do some research on this. That
would be Founded Earth Brothers. They
did an amazing job on kind of finding
that stuff and they did it on their own.
They have a video on this as well and
what you're going to find next is all
the stuff I found on my own and I was
connections were already being made.
We have
some interesting things happening.
In fact, there is a deep and deliberate
connection between Yahweh
and Jupiter.
Especially in Roman, Greek, and later
Masonic and Jesuit traditions. Our
understanding both Saturn and Jupiter in
relation to Yahweh is essential to
exposing the full Luciferian hijacking
of God's name.
You see what I found is that in sat in
mythology, classic mythology,
Saturn, also known as Cronus, is the
father of the gods.
The harsh ruler of time, death, and
restriction.
And Jupiter, also known as Zeus, is his
son.
He overthrows Saturn and becomes the
king of the gods.
Associated with lightning, kingship, and
judgment.
These two gods represent duality.
The old tyrant and the new enlightened
ruler.
But both are Luciferian in different
masks.
Here is why I can say that.
First of all, let's remind ourselves
that Saturnalia, which we know as
Christmas, is based around the idea of
Saturn. Saturn used to eat his children,
and this was probably the least
grotesque picture of that that I could
find.
Next, we have
Jupiter Optimus Maximus, or just
Jupiter. We see that after Constantine
and the Roman Empire adopted
Christianity,
they merged the worship of Jupiter with
the biblical God of the Tetragrammaton
named Yahweh.
Jupiter Optimus Maximus, known as the
supreme God of Rome, became the model
for the Latinized version of God the
Father.
The image of God as a
thunderbolt-wielding sky king sitting in
a temple was imported directly from Zeus
and Jupiter worship.
This is why,
as we are going to see now,
the Vatican dome is modeled after
Jupiter temples.
That, of course,
is
St. Peter's Basilica literally sits on
top, as you might know or might not
know.
It sits on top of a former Zeus and
Jupiter temple.
The Pope's titles
reflect Jupiterian high priesthood,
specifically Pontifex Maximus.
Many biblical scholars, translators, and
even pastors
have unknowingly or knowingly misled the
world by inserting false names and pagan
titles for the creator.
The name Yahweh, linked to the God
of the Romans named Jupiter
or Yove, such as we heard from Nehemiah.
And the Greek Zeus is one such
deception.
A simple study reveals that the true
memorial name of God,
written in four Hebrew letters, was
Yahuah, and was distorted by Jerome's
Latin Vulgate into Yahweh.
Violating the structure of ancient
Paleo-Hebrew, which never used the
letters E or O,
J,
V,
or W.
The W itself was actually pronounced a
double U, like an Ooh.
When Jesus revealed the true nature of
God the Father, it was not a distinct
force
or Saturnian tyrant like they said of
Jupiter
and Saturn.
He rebuked the religious elites when
Jesus spoke, exposing their rituals and
refusing to participate in their magic
systems. Parallel to Rome's religious
hub,
located atop the city's highest hill,
which is a temple to Jupiter Optimus
Maximus on the Capitoline or Collis
Capitolinus
in Latin,
the US Capitol,
the nation's central legislative
building was built on a small rise
dubbed Capitol Hill.
The names of the hill and the building
are spelled with an O
after Rome's Capitoline.
I might not be saying that right, but
you get the point.
Other urban features of DC
that echo ancient Rome include the mon-
monumental scale of federal buildings
and the inclusion of plazas for public
and civil statutory
like the equestrian statue of Andrew
Jackson.
DC's mall even is mo- modeled on the
political, religious, and cultural
center of the Roman Forum. In the Bible,
we see that it says no man knoweth the
Father but the Son.
So, in some ways, we're going to have to
look at what Jesus called
God, his Father.
He says, "I have manifested thy name
unto the men which thou gavest me."
And he It also says in Revelation 2:9,
"They say they are Jews and are not,
but are the synagogue
of Satan."
What we do know is that we do come to a
point where Kabbalists and occultists
have to come in.
Where they've twisted the sacred name of
Yahweh into a Saturnian God, often
worshipped in secret rituals while
appearing outwardly religious. There's a
reason for this, and we're going to get
into it just in a few seconds.
This perversion of God's name is part of
the Antichrist system, which Jesus
directly confronted.
Only by following Jesus Christ of
Nazareth,
and I'll add the Son of God,
not mysticism and not religion, do we
know the true
Yahweh,
the Father of lights,
which is really, I guess,
from what they're saying.
Not in all cases, he does have many
names, but I guess it does show up as
Jehovah.
Not
the dark lord of the cube, which Saturn
is known as the dark lord of the cube.
Witches who have come to know God are
very conscientious of this to pray
to Jesus Christ of Nazareth, the Son of
God.
In some ancient cultural and
philosophical contexts, Yahweh was not
only misunderstood, but deliberately
This is where I want you guys to
understand a little bit more of why this
became a blended synthesis of
misunderstanding.
Let me start that again.
In some ancient cultural and
philosophical contexts,
Yahweh was not only misunderstood, but
deliberately demonized
and equated with other deities by rival
religious groups.
For example, in Hellenistic Egypt,
Yahweh was sometimes equated with the
chaotic God Set
and depicted with a donkey-like head
as a form of religious slander against
Jews and early Christians,
reflecting deep-seated polemics and
hostile reinterpretations
of Israel's God,
causing a melding and synthesis in
various Gnostic traditions
developed
into a concept of the Demiurge.
Okay?
So, we can see
taking a pic- a look at that picture,
there's a donkey head depicted in
several different ways.
In the Syrian
and on cuneiform.
So crazy.
In Egypt, many times over,
this Yahweh God was known
as a donkey-headed God.
All right.
So, the Demiurge,
it promotes a flawed, ignorant creator
of the material world, who they used to
call Yaldabaoth
or Yaldaboth. I've heard both.
And identified with the God of the Old
Testament Testament,
portraying him as a lesser, oppressive
ruler, distinct from the supreme
spiritual God
recognized in Orthodox Christianity.
So, let's just take a look at this
picture real quick. I'm sorry if it
might be small, but I'll read it from
the top.
It says, "Thus, the seven planets were
the seven old gods of the Baby-
Babylonians,
Shamash,
which is the sun,
Sin, the moon, Nebo, which was Mercury,
Ishtar, which was Venus, Nergal, which
is Mars, Marduk, which is Jupiter,
and
Ea, which is Saturn. I've also heard
Saturn be El.
Okay? I'm not going to go any further
into that. You have all those symbols
in the Kabbalah,
which are supposed to represent the
menorah and all that stuff.
And then I just gave an example on the
right, the Gnostic code forbidden wisdom
of the Demiurge and Sophia.
Okay?
Sophia is the girl he
becomes a couple with and has children,
and so on. The mythology continues of
their children and stuff.
But,
as it goes,
the Kabbalists
have a blend, as I said,
of Saturn and Jupiter in their
mythology.
In Jewish mysticism, which is what
Kabbalism is,
you have the tree of life.
Here you see many different views of
that.
The Norse
Yggdrasil, I guess, which is their tree,
the Assyrian sacred tree, the Hebrew
Kabbalah tree of life, the Egyptian,
and witchcraft. You have spirit, water,
air, earth, and fire.
But, in this, you have Saturn.
If you get close enough, you can see
that one part of it is all the
characteristics of Saturn, and the other
is Jupiter.
For mercy and expansion and dominionism,
and then judgment, law, and severity.
Yahweh
in the Tetragrammaton is placed at
different sephirots,
depending, so different points on the
tree, depending on the ritual usage.
Sometimes tied to Saturnian severity,
sometimes
to Jupiterian kingship.
In effect,
Yahweh becomes a dual-faced alchemical
god.
Saturn equals restriction,
hidden order, and the black cube,
while Jupiter equals expansion,
rulership, and glory.
This dualism is not biblical.
It is alchemy.
And it echoes Lucifer's desire to be
like the most high, possessing both
judgment and glory, darkness and light.
You can see on the left seven gates on
the Kabbalah tree of life that are
aligned with the chakras.
So, anybody using the chakras in yoga
and so on,
are using the same thing.
It does open up chakras, which are
portals
to spirits and demons to enter you.
In biblical Hebrew,
Yahweh is the true,
they say, is the true name of God
revealed to Moses.
However, Kabbalists believe this name,
like we're saying, is a Tetragrammaton.
What does that mean? We're going to
unearth that with a few clues right now.
We're going to take a look at one in
just a minute,
or towards the end, I should say.
Meaning
that
a Tetragrammaton encodes hidden energy
formulas,
sexual duality, and alchemical power.
This deeply means that in the occult and
Kabbalistic traditions,
the Tetragrammaton is used as a mystical
chant
or formula
to invoke spiritual entities or open
portals.
Repurposing God's name for ritualistic
demonic access.
They break the name apart, reassign it
to the tree of life um on the sephirot,
and encode it in symbols like the
hexagram and the cube, using numerology,
and often using it in a astrological,
magical, or Saturnian rituals.
Kabbalists and occultists do not worship
the true God of the Bible.
They manipulate divine names in magical
systems
in their numerology and rituals, as I
already mentioned.
And the the name, unfortunately, that I
found
that they use the most is Yahweh.
It is central in their mystical
invocations.
In many esoteric systems, the name Yah
is associated with Saturn worship,
as well as the divine masculine
in dualistic occultism,
paired with Shekinah or the feminine
goddess Sophia worship.
In Gnostic and Hermetic systems, Yahweh
is often not seen not as the most high
God, but as a demiurge or lesser god, as
I mentioned.
It's the same false god that Luciferians
believe that they can overthrow. When we
talk about Yah
or Yahoo, it comes to the fact that
these names are found in ancient pagan
nations.
This picture, by the way, is how the
alchemy symbols work.
You have Saturn on there. You have
Jupiter. You have Rebis. You have male
and female.
And they do believe through these things
that through sexual power
and other things, rituals,
you can obtain enlightenment and so on.
On the right, you have what we know as
the zodiac wheel,
which we need to take one step further.
This is where we get
the Kabbalah Seal of Solomon.
Now, I'm going to let you look at that.
I had to cover up the middle cuz um they
did show
his private parts on there.
But, there's there's more.
Because variations of Yah, Yahoo, or
Iao, which is the Greek form of the
Tetragrammaton, were used in Babylonian,
Egyptian, and Greek mystery religions.
Evidence of the divine name in magical
papyrus,
incantations, and pagan talismans
will suggest
these weren't exclusive to Hebrew
believers, but were adopted and
corrupted. In the occult and Masonic
traditions, Yahweh is syncretized with
Saturn, the god of law, time,
limitation, and judgment.
Let me put it together for you a little
bit more. I've spoken on this so many
times, not this particular thing, but
I've made the connection before.
Saturn was also known as El
and Cronus.
Cronus
governs time,
and it's said
that Saturn governs time as a grim
reaper.
And the black cube of Saturn is placed
over the name Yahweh
to represent this constraining,
controlling force.
Some Jewish mystics, Gnostics, and
Luciferian sects
elevate Saturn,
using the name Yahweh as the hidden god
or true ruler of the material world.
This is why Saturn's cube is present in
many Jewish and Islamic sacred places,
the Kaaba in Mecca,
for instance, and the tefillin black
cube box worn during Jewish prayer.
We're going to get back to that.
So, here is where
we have been on this picture, as I was
saying all of that, we need to break
down
what we have here.
Here is where they actually take numbers
and assign it to
Tetragrammaton,
okay, which is supposed to represent
Yahweh.
And they have certain symbols for all of
the different kinds of
Saturn.
Okay, you have male or female. You have
males there.
You have Jupiter here and Jupiter there.
You have some symbols in here that are
not so good,
and in between here,
even in Hebrew.
I want to make the point that this sage
that's burning here and the tarot cards,
this is an actual
Kabbalistic witch. I know that some
people are new to this, like
they go together, hand in hand.
A lot of what we're talking about is
witchcraft right now.
And it's on the person's altar. It's in
their magic practices.
This Seal of Solomon is what a lot of
occultists and
witches and all these people use
different seals of different types with
different variations of the pentagram,
as someone mentioned. Yes, it is a
pentagram.
To take down messages of numerological
value,
and also summon demons. They also wear
it as a pendant.
Okay? And it says down below, the divine
name Yahweh means I will be whoever I
will be, or I will be whatever I will
be.
Not I am that I am. That's a very
significant alteration of God's name.
All right? Here is where I got that
picture
of Solomon's coin. You see it there.
You see the other side is very much just
covered in spiral Hebrew writing.
And we need to read about
the 72 names of God and Tetragrammaton
coin.
All right? Cuz it's going to spell out a
lot.
It says, it is a double-sided brass coin
inspired by classic Kabbalistic and
Solomonic
symbolism. One side features the
tetragrammaton, the four-letter Hebrew
name of God,
Yahweh,
Y H W H.
Central design incorporates a pentagram
enclosed within a circle, reflecting
traditional symbolic geometry.
This is where you could probably put it
right in there, and I'm going to just
say it, Freemasonry. Go straight in this
box as well when it's geometry.
Includes planetary and elemental
symbols. There you go, alchemy's coming
in.
Associated with
historical esoteric diagrams. You also
have astrology coming in.
It features Hebrew inscriptions such as
Yahweh, Adam, and Keter
drawn from Kabbalistic tradition.
The design references symbolic elements
including the Seal of Solomon, the
caduceus, alpha and omega, and the
ouroboros.
We know the ouroboros is not good.
And it combines motives motifs, sorry,
from biblical, Kabbalistic, and
classical symbolic sources.
The reverse side is engraved with the 72
names of God in Hebrew letter sequences
created as a historical, cultural, and
symbolic collectible.
All right, so that's what we need to
know. And by the way, those 72 names of
God are all said to be in a letter
sequence almost as though it's a spell.
You use the name of Yahweh, you name you
use all the different names of him, not
coming from a biblical perspective at
all. You use it as chants, as spells, as
incantations,
mantras, what have you.
Here, we even have a connection with
Yah, the god I mentioned before that's
also connected
with
this
Yahweh
pronunciation.
It is the moon deity in Egypt. They say
this is the origin of the
fictional character Yahweh also,
which came from another source, and
that's what they believe.
All right, I'm going to read this to you
which kind of blew my mind. This is from
Big Think. It says, "Yahweh worship can
be traced back
all the way to the ancient religion of
Canaan."
In the northwestern Semitic language
spoken there, El
had multiple meanings.
It was the word for God, the name of a
specific god,
and the title of a god who stood removed
from other lesser gods.
These lesser gods included Yahweh,
who was assigned the land of Israel.
In time, the Israelites referred to
Yahweh as El Shaddai, God Almighty.
All right, so here we get to the really
strange part, I believe. It also has
everything to do with you UFOology.
All right, guys, just listen up here.
This guy says the Old Testament written
in Hebrew taught him how to summon UFOs.
All right, he says he can also do this
on command, and he adds he's been doing
it for 25 years keeping all of it secret
until now.
These beings are here. They are here.
They're just sitting right up there. We
met up with Prophet Yahweh, seer of
Yahweh, at a little park off Lake Mead.
We picked the day, we picked the time,
and we picked the location. Everyone's
going to think you're absolutely nuts.
Well, I thought I was absolutely nuts.
Until he says he saw UFOs over the
years, 1,500 of them. Can we make it
1,501 today? What do you think? I'll try
it. He says the voice in his head told
him to go public now, so we took him up
on his offer, and we scanned the skies.
Nothing but a few clouds. When the
prophet started praying for a sighting,
I wasn't exactly convinced. I pray oh
Yahweh that you send a sighting so that
they know that I am not mentally ill. I
am not a false prophet
like those who seek to kill me say I am.
I'll give you something straight up.
Oh. Bro, look at it. There it is. You
can barely see it, a white speck. Then,
another sighting. There it is. I got I
got it. I got it. I got it.
Photojournalist Jonathan Hawkins locks
in on it. Let's take a closer look here.
It's an orange sphere that appeared out
of nowhere. I called the boss with an
unexpected change in my story.
I I can see it as clear as day. In fact,
it's bright. I can't believe this.
It's It's moving pretty fast. It's going
to Nellis Air Force Base. It wants to be
seen. We called Nellis to see what these
things might be. Guess what? They didn't
call us back, but this thing started
coming back toward us. It's coming
toward us now, I think.
What? See, it's coming up toward us.
Whoa, man!
Oh, hallelujah!
Then, a few seconds later, it
disappeared. It's going back up in
space.
Prophet Yahweh isn't concerned. He says
it'll be back.
And I'm still not quite sure what those
things were now.
So, it is
I think interesting to note that
with that being said that this man was
trying to
well, did conjure up and was able to
call
UFOs, um
with in the name of Yahweh, speaking it,
praying to it.
And we've seen that,
um
if you're listening or have listened to
what Mikey has spoken on before with the
alien stuff,
you know that many people have been
saved from abductions and stuff
using the name of Jesus.
So, you you see that duality there. You
see that
they can summon
the UFOs, which I know are demons,
with the name of Yahweh.
And they can be freed
from abduction and so on using the name
of Jesus.
There's There's just that.
Here is what I was mentioning.
There are cubes
of Saturn everywhere in the world.
We see that in Christ's time, the
Pharisees and teachers of the law were
already steeped in Babylonian influence,
oral traditions, and what they
would evolve what would evolve into
Talmudism and Kabbalism. You can see
right here on the screen the black cube
of Mecca
and the tefillin which they wear on
their head.
You also see that they use the name of
God,
it says in the Bible,
we spoke about this before, but follow
after their father, the devil.
In John
8:44,
proving that just using the name Yahweh
doesn't mean
anyone worships the true God.
Jesus exposed them for following
man-made traditions using external
ritual and secret mystical teachings all
the time.
Many Zionist, Freemasonic, and Jesuit
systems today still invoke
Yahweh in rituals, but it's not the god
of scripture,
as we're seeing.
It is Satur- Saturn cloaked in the
divine name,
a counterfeit
of Yahweh sometimes paired with Sophia,
Shekinah in the Kabbalah, promoting
androgyny
and duality. And yes, if if you're new
again to this, androgyny on that
alchemical symbol and even on the
pentagram, one of those symbols we saw
is
called the rebis, and it means you reach
a state
it's certain sexual positions as well or
rituals, and one of them is being
androgynous.
Even some Messianic or Hebrew roots
groups unknowingly repeat Kabbalistic
prayers
or revere Jewish mystics who saw Yahweh
as an impersonal force, but not a
personal holy god or father.
In Freemasonry and Jesuit rituals,
the god they worship is often ref-
referred to simply as the great
architect, which is code for Jupiter,
Zeus,
and Yahweh together, depending on the
degree and the branch.
The eye in the triangle,
which often is said to be Yahweh or El
Elyon, is frequently tied to Jupiter as
the king of heaven.
Interesting, because when it tells you
not to worship the goddesses of
mysticism in the Bible, it says the
queen of heaven. Here you have the king
of heaven.
In the Jesuit IHS monogram, often said
to to mean Jesus,
it's also historically referred to
as the Roman Jupiter,
I H S or
Iasis Hominum
Salvator.
If you're doing the Roman Jupiter thing.
But if you're doing
the Egyptian thing, it's Isis, Horus,
Set,
depending on the version. It
is a system. It's a method they're
using, and it's blasphemous and
confusing by design
to blend Christ with Jupiter and make
people worship a false god under the
name of Yahweh
is what I came to.
Why is Satan doing this? Well, he took
Saturn as the hidden face.
Look at all those cubes, by the way. As
I'm saying this, look at all these
cubes. He's taking
all the Saturn worship as the hidden
face of God.
From mystery schools,
the Jews outrightly in Israel and in
Judaism,
and using the black cube
to get people to worship everywhere.
And seeing that they have memorials for
this, I don't know, it speaks for
itself, doesn't it? This is hard to
speak about sometimes
because when we then take Jupiter,
we need to realize
that behind the scenes of Saturn
is the actual public face
of God that they've given us
to use in our churches and in our
governments and Catholicism and and all
religions up front.
So, they're preaching
using the name that stands for Jupiter
while hiding the true religion
that they are pushing, which is
Saturn worship. Because of that duality
of both of the two together.
And they've merged them both into
Yahweh.
So, that all roads
lead to him. Do you understand?
All roads lead to him.
Meaning Yahweh.
Not the true God of the Bible.
This is why many religious denominations
worship
a god named Yahweh
or just the Lord.
But their doctrine reflects Jupiter and
Saturn.
Not the father of Jesus Christ.
Here I have more proof real quick that
Saturn is a secret god of the occult
world.
Saturn worship is everywhere from logos
to secret societies and that's You saw
the other cubes, here's more. Here's the
different logos.
And here we also see, this is a good
point.
I'm glad I'm taking a little more time.
This is how the Freemasons see and
represent their god.
They do write it
Yahweh with a W, Yahweh with a V.
You can see that on the right.
And they also know him
connected with
the triangle
with the eye in it.
And they're making the connection right
here. I took this straight from a
Masonic posting.
It says Jehovah
in their words,
I guess in their doctrine is Baal.
And Yahweh is Baal. They also call this
god Yabulan, the great architect of the
universe.
So, straight from their mouths, there
you have it. So, this connection with
Baal worship comes out of the woodwork.
And it says in Jeremiah 23:26-27,
"How long shall this be in the heart of
the prophets that prophesy lies?
Yea, they are prophets of the deceit of
their own heart,
which think to cause my people to forget
my name
by their dreams, which they tell every
man to their neighbor,
as their fathers have forgotten my name
for Baal."
Interesting that God is giving us clues.
This is a good point as well. It says,
"Scholar Nissim Amzallag
of Ben-Gurion University disagrees with
the claim that Yahweh's origins are
obscure and argues that the deity was
originally a god of the forge and patron
of metallurgists
metallurgists
during the Bronze Age.
Amzallag
specifically cites the ancient copper
mines of the Timna Valley, which they
found ruins in, by the way,
biblical and extra-biblical passages and
similarities of Yahweh to gods of
metallurgy in other cultures for
support. Although the Bible and
specifically the Book of Exodus presents
Yahweh as the god of the Israelites,
there are many passages which make clear
that this deity was also worshipped by
other people in Canaan.
Amzallag notes that the
Kenites, Moabites, and Midianites all
worshipped Yahweh to one degree or
another.
And that there is evidence the
who operated the mines at Timna,
converted an earlier Egyptian temple of
Hathor. Many of you have mentioned
Hathor in the chats as we're going on.
Yes, this is where it comes into
to the worship of Yahweh. Let's continue
right down in the last paragraph. It
says, "Although
the biblical narratives depict Yahweh as
the sole creator god,
lord of the universe and god of the
Israelites especially,
initially he seems to have been
Canaanite in origin
and subordinate to the supreme god El.
We're putting it together, aren't we? El
was also
Saturn
or Cronus.
And that was his father, so he would be
subordinate to him.
And Yahweh
is Jupiter.
So, I I needed to hear this because once
again the connection's being made to
Canaanites.
By the way,
Kenites, Moabites, and Midianites are
all
if you go back and read the Bible, it's
just occurring to me, so I don't have
the verse.
These are all peoples that
God had to find a way of helping the
Israelites wipe them out because they
were such an ungodly people. They had to
be cleansed from the earth.
And that sounds terrible. I don't, you
know, he's going to do
his judgment at the end of the world,
but
they were unacceptable
to God.
In Freemasonry, Yahweh, represented by
the Hebrew Tetragrammaton
or
Anglicized as Jehovah, is considered the
ineffable name of the supreme being and
is a crucial foundational word in
Masonic ritual,
particularly in the Royal Arch and
Scottish Rite degrees. It represents the
divine, frequently appearing on the
altar and within symbolism to signify I
am that I am.
So, that's been changed. We know that
that's not what it really stands for
anymore.
But it's often referenced in the context
of the creator or the grand architect of
the universe.
We'll go down the page all the way to
almost the bottom where it says G
symbol. That's
interesting that they're proving my
point. "While G often stands for God or
geometry, in some context it can be
linked to the sacredness of the divine
name." So, whose divine name? Who is
actually promoting this?
Well, as I mentioned, Kabbalism,
occultists, Freemasons, Jesuits, in
their highest orders, mind you.
So, we know from start to finish
now that the name Yahweh has been
hijacked. The one world religion, the
tree of life system, and the interfaith
coexist movement,
they are all pretending to worship God,
the true God, using biblical names. But
this isn't the god of Abraham, Isaac,
and Jacob. It's a counterfeit.
A Baal rebranded as Yahweh.
Meant to seduce all nations into
worshipping the beast.
If the so-called Yahweh at the top of
the Kaaba
and Kabbalah is the same one calling for
unity through sorcery,
sun worship, sacred geometry, and denial
of Christ,
then that's not the true Yahweh.
That's Satan in disguise and the world
is being prepped to worship him through
false religion.
This is why we all need to take a look.
We all need to listen up.
Listen to what Jesus referred to his
father as.
He calls his father Abba, literally
daddy or father.
He says, "My God, my God, why have you
forsaken me?"
He said the world doesn't know him in
John 17:25.
And he exposes the temple leaders who
thought they served God,
but really of their father, the devil,
again in John 8:44.
"And this is eternal life,
that they might know
thee, the only true God,
and Jesus Christ,
whom you have sent."
That was John
17:3.
But down below it
in verse six,
it says, "I have manifested thy name
unto the men which thou gavest me."
As we saw, all mankind on the face of
this earth is dealing with man-made
religions, either which reflect Saturn,
restriction, the cube, and the law, or
Jupiter, power, kingship, and lightning.
Don't take those symbols too far, but
it's neither of them that's the true
father of Jesus.
The true
father
of Jesus is holy, set apart, not
dualistic. He never changes. He is fully
revealed through his son. There's no
cube.
There's no thunderbolts. And there's no
triangle eye.
Many today, as we've said,
coming from all different walks,
they've been telling you, "You need to
look into this. You need to
call God by a certain name."
Let me tell you something that hit me
deeply and is still
where I stand.
Romans 10:13,
"For whosoever shall call upon the name
of the Lord shall be saved."
Christ transcends language,
culture,
and man-made titles.
In Acts 2, we can see the Holy Spirit
allowed every listener to hear the truth
in his own language.
That means that he's not confined by any
certain language at all. Whether that be
Hebrew, Greek, Latin, English, Spanish,
Swahili.
In fact, we are all going to learn
different names for God.
But,
it's not based on phonetics.
Countless saints are coming to Christ
using the name that they know for him.
They're being saved. They're being
healed.
And called upon God in many different
languages.
The Holy Spirit reveals the son of God.
Not a magical name chant.
And I might add that just knowing
supposedly the name of Yahweh or Yah or
Yeshua is not
going to save you.
Some people think that's what is going
to be put in our foreheads as we're
marked for God to go to heaven, but
if that's all you think is going to save
you and calling upon him with that name,
you missed that mark.
It's all about becoming
like him. It's your character and the
fruits that you show,
not what name you use for him.
Of course, we should not be using
names of other gods for him at all.
That's the point of this.
And did we Did any of us really know
this? No.
I don't think so.
So, this is new to me. This is what I
found.
And
I believe, based on that, that I can say
that the sacred name
part of this is a deception.
And it because dealing with other people
who have
firmly been planted on that, I believe I
can say that sacred name
ideology
reflects
and lean leads itself to appeal to
pride.
It says, "I know the true name.
You don't. You better look into it."
It denies grace,
which says you must pronounce his name
this way to be saved.
And if you don't, then there's no grace
or mercy for you.
It seems to distort identity, meaning
that it turns Jesus, the word made
flesh, into a linguistic puzzle game.
And it opens the door to much legalism,
mysticism, as we've seen, idolatry and
paganism, and even
eventually Kabbalism, if it isn't
already in your life when you've done
that.
Where divine names are tools and powers
rather than reflections of God's love.
What I've come to know
in the Bible
is that his name shall be called Jesus,
it says.
"For he shall save his people from their
sins." Matthew 1:21.
The name Jesus is not a mistranslation
or mistake.
It's the transliteral
into Greek,
sorry, transliteration into Greek, then
English of the same name.
Jesus of Nazareth, the son of God,
the creator,
all those distinction distinctions make
Satan flee. I know that.
Yahweh does not.
In fact, it invokes demons, as we just
saw and as we are seeing.
We need to be careful. And Jesus of
Nazareth is the only begotten son of the
Father. And that's, as I said,
there's power there.
I do have proof and I have videos that
have shown occultists and witches coming
out
who become Christians, and they make
sure every time they pray to be very
specific about it being Jesus of
Nazareth, the son of God,
son of the Father,
and the creator.
I believe, if I'm
quoting this correctly,
I believe even Roger Morneau
said that Satan cannot create. He's
envious of that power.
And as we know, Jesus was the one in
the Godhead that was given the creative
power, and God sat back and took
pleasure in seeing his son do so.
So, Satan is trying to counterfeit
heavily.
So, you can cry out, "God, help me." or
"Jesus, save me." in desperation, and he
hears.
He doesn't need the correct Hebrew vowel
markers
or the consent of a rabbi.
And there's much confusion being brought
on by this.
The Holy Spirit,
I might add, makes Christ known, not
Hebrew linguistics
or reading the original in Hebrew.
Jesus Christ of Nazareth, once again, I
will end on this, transcends all
man-made names
and languages and cultures.
He is a name above
every name.
And if he was the one who made
languages, he knows
the kind of confusion that was going to
be coming about. He knows,
such as we saw, he's leaving clues in
scripture that they've taken up a
different name,
which leads them to be
sons of the devil and
associated with Baal.
But he wants us to know
that he is a savior. He is our Messiah,
our Jesus,
the son of God,
and everything else.
Think about this for a second, and this
is just coming to mind, but there will
be Native Americans that never knew
about
Jesus,
the name or any such name.
And maybe they were only given the name
Great Chief in the Sky.
Or something like that that it sounds
very, you know,
pantheistic or new age, but they had the
right idea. Somehow the Holy Spirit
showed them who God really was, and they
prayed to him, and they were saved.
It changed their character. They
cooperated with his spirit, and
they show
all the markings of God within them.
That's all we need. We need to be
cooperative like that.
Not utter names of paganism and
idolatry, but and worship as the
heathens do, but we
quite honestly need to use the names
that we've
come to know as true names
of God, even if it is from
different culture, different language.
God will hear you.
He promises that over and over again, by
the way.
If you pray in the name of Jesus and you
believe,
he will hear you.
So,
I hope you guys liked it.
I hope this clears up a lot. For me, it
was quite the undertaking, and
this is just everything I found.
Ironically, it was strange to see how
the pieces came together from Founded
Earth Brothers to what I found and how
they all connected.
We do have merchandise on our page,
candidtruth.org,
if you want to go look there.
And we also have, if you feel so called,
we have all of our
platforms where you can go and donate to
our ministry.
We do need your help. We have
initiatives. We have all kinds of plans
that we
do need funding for to make happen.
So, if you feel called, please do so.
Thank you guys.
May God bless you, and may we go
into truth,
walking the straight and narrow path.
May God be with every one of you.